[Music]
hi everyone my name is Sarah random
facts about me I don't have a large
intestine yeah that's because I have
Crohn's disease also an IBD and advocate
who runs a website and a YouTube channel
my name is Dan sharp
i'ma Crohn's patient and in IBD advocate
that's what this channel is about it's
about my life with Crohn's disease if
you don't know what that is then all the
more reason to subscribe and figure out
how I [ __ ] I'm trying to show that good
information is accessible to patients
you don't have to be a scientist or
doctor to go and figure out this stuff
[Music]
now with the Internet patients can have
a lot more information that's the way
the world is going
I've used a phrase previously that I
borrowed from somebody that it takes a
village to take care of my B deviation
and to me that village includes other
patients Crohn's is a type of IBD IV d
stands for inflammatory bowel disease
really it's a group of disorders or
conditions
wherein the immune system has an
overactive response to something in the
digestive tract and ends up causing
inflammation and damage these aren't
like any other chronic medical condition
sometimes people call these the
invisible diseases because they'll say
something like well you look fine you
might as well be okay imagine then if
you have a bowel condition that provides
you with a lack of control or a feeling
like you don't know what's going to
happen next you are unable to plan for
the future and you may not actually have
people around you who understand it
enough to help you or to support you the
way you need I started advocacy in a
weird way it wasn't it wasn't till like
three years after my first two surgeries
but I ended up in the hospital again
so to fill my time and to feel like
something was happening in my day I just
opened my computer one day and turned on
my webcam and started talking to the
camera and started sharing my story and
uploading that to YouTube and then it
turned into what it is today I think
that it's important that the right story
about IBD gets
out there to the general public that's
why I share what I do I want to just
break down the stigma that is all we are
is people that are running to the
bathroom all the time because that's
definitely not my life and it's not a
lot of our lives the more that I
uploaded videos and I saw the response
and patients responded to it so well I
was like okay I'm doing a good thing
like this is okay and it inspired me to
talk my advocacy something I'm really
passionate about is helping patients be
empowered with information I think more
that a patient knows about their
condition the better decisions they can
make about the health the better they
can advocate in themselves in a
healthcare setting like they know what
questions to ask things like that
the traditional model of patience
learning about their disease came from a
much more paternalistic relationship
with their doctors the doctor would tell
them what they had and what they needed
to do and the patient either would do it
or they wouldn't but more often than not
they would do it we evolved into the
appreciation for shared decision-making
and shared decision-making was augmented
by the growth of the internet now at the
same time we also learned a lot more
about how patients make decisions and
the value of other educational fora
including YouTube videos now whenever
you open up channels of information
there's also the challenge of facing
misinformation rather than be threatened
by that I think physicians and nurses
need to be open to that dialogue and
understand what's out there this is
groundbreaking stuff okay you're gone I
know Dan and Sarah very well he's pretty
much everywhere there we go if we go to
a conference or something he's most
likely presenting at least ones there I
actually look up to them and I respect
what they do greatly in fact I think
that they really believe and I
completely support their role as saying
you know what we're not part of the
medical establishment but we're informed
and we want you to know that what you're
saying isn't right and what has been
necessary in order for them to do that
so effectively is for them to actually
attend medical conferences to not be
afraid of learning the science and
challenging the science and you know I
might not be a doctor but I'm a smart
person I'm capable of learning a lot so
I put my time and energy into
researching things making sure I get the
right information and then I always
check it before I publish it I have a
lot of doctors on the internet that have
been so kind to me and let me weave
messaged them late at night on Twitter
and be like hey I have a question and
I'm not afraid to give feedback if I
think they're misdirecting people
because it's going to happen either way
you might as well be doing it and
working together then having any kind of
fear of what that means I always kind of
joke around about like well if a doctor
retweets it then that means I did a good
job
they were saying that this was good
information that I'm like yeah the
information I was taught by my mentor
that all the research we do should start
and end with the patient who suffers and
that may sound completely obvious but
the reality is that in research a lot of
times it's that there are certain things
being studied because patients in the
IVD community are speaking up and so for
years what was the number-one topic on
the internet that wasn't able to be
answered sufficiently in the IVD
research arena I would say that it was
diet-related there's a study going on
right now through the CCFA about
studying two different kinds of diets
and what effect they might have on
inflammatory bowel disease that's an
area that a lot of patients feel are
important but that I really think was a
crowd source I think that anyone who's
not paying attention to what's going on
out there is turning a blind eye on the
most important information that they
could have about what research needs to
be done
good luck
you